well amid a rise in covid cases health
officials say there are right now no
plans to return to a face
mask mandate the southern nevada health
district simply emphasizing that
everybody get their vaccine especially
younger people who have been reluctant
that is to do so
a recent spike in cases raising red
flags as
vaccination rates now slow down so this
means the risk to get the virus is still
growing
even for those who are fully vaccinated
and i know that some people have the
misconception that if i had covet at one
point in the past if i was infected that
i am immune
that immune immunity is entirely
different than what immunity that comes
from the vaccine so
if you have uh had covet at some point
in the past you still
need to get vaccinated and get this 95
percent of people in clark county who
have died or have been hospitalized
because of covid in the last three
months
have not been vaccinated you can check
out eightnewsnow.com and our free mobile
app for a list of those at vaccination
locations